- [Kelly] First of all, y'all are
the most adorable thing to
walk into the room together.
(laughter)
It's so cute.
And secondly, do you
bring all the shows gifts?
Like what's that for?
- Well, I heard there was a birthday girl.
- Oh!
- But I do have something for you
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- Well, from us
when you have a birthday.
- [Kelly] Oh okay.
Do you want me to open it now?
- I just signed the card.
She showed up, it was
wrapped, she had the card.
Just sign that.
- [Kelly] You sound like
such a man right now.
I just signed it.
I have no idea what you got.
Wait, I'm gonna do...
Oh wait, what is this?
Oh, it's so...
Hey, did you know that I'm actually
really into rocks and gems?
Did you know that?
You did.
- Yup
- Oh.
Thank you so much for
having us on your show.
This is so sweet, thank you guys!
(applause)
That's so nice.
So Riley just--
Yes, Riley just went out
to her "Frozen" party
and I hear you used to
love "Frozen" too, right?
- Loved it.
Like when the first movie came out
it was like one of the biggest movies.
Like I watched it every night
and then I'd cry whenever
Elsa and her sister...
- Me too.
- I love that movie.
"Let It Go" is such an original song.
- It's so great.
Have you seen "Frozen Two"?
- Yes!
- I loved it.
I'm 37, I don't care.
♪ Into the unknown ♪
Yes.
I sing it along with my
daughter and I don't care.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, you're never
too old to love Disney.
Yes, okay.
(audience applauds)
So what, were you ever into like cartoons
when you were a kid?
- I was, yeah.
- Which ones?
- I was that little kid, I
grew up in front of a TV.
Well they were usually
like, the superhero cartoons
or you know, "Dating Myself",
but like, "Fat Albert"
was one of my favorites.
- "Fat Albert", yeah, that's great.
- Yeah, I'm a seventies kid.
- That's awesome, that's a good one.
So you're being inducted
into the WWE, right?
The hall of fame.
- Yeah, the hall of fame.
- That's amazing!
(audience applauds)
- Congratulations.
- Yeah, thank you.
I appreciate it, yeah.
- I gotta be real with
you, if I'm in any space
where you're about to fight
me I'm just running away.
- No, I'm actually, I'm the
nicest person in this room.
I guarantee.
- I'm just saying,
yeah but you're also the
most terrifying looking
if you're gonna get a fight with you.
- It's helped me (laughs).
It's weird it's like
in here it's all gushy
and it's like rainbows and butterflies.
- Oh, that's the best.
- Yeah, but I have that,
I guess I have that look.
I look like (laughs)
I always tease people.
All right, I always tease.
I'll say this about myself
as I look like I just broke out of prison.
(laughter)
- That looks pretty cool.
Did you have to give Chloe any tips
on like being an action star?
- No, we talked more about I think drama
and bouncing off each other.
- Yeah.
- And just acting in general.
No action tips, but we
worked on a few facials
and what not, you know, expressions.
- Yeah.
- Wait, what, what's the face expression?
- Well my publicist has dubbed it
resting action face.
(laughter)
- Resting action--
- Because I have, yeah, cause
like I said, I usually look
intimidating, but I'm
usually happy inside,
but I just have resting action face.
- Yes, can I see it?
Like what's--
- Yeah, do you wanna see Chloe's first?
- I wanna see Chloe's real bad.
Yes oh my God, you could...
(audience applauds)
It was far scarier from a little human.
(laughs)
That was really too good,
Chloe, what is yours like?
- Which camera are we working with?
- Okay, you're working there.
- That one there?
Cause it all up in here.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- You need to get a good look at this.
- Get in there.
Uh-oh.
Oh my goodness.
(laughs)
That's my favorite.
That was totally Drax, from
"Guardians of the Galaxy".
- That's who I am.
- Okay, okay.
So I can do it, I can do it.
I'm gonna do it right now, are you ready?
Where's the camera?
Where am I looking?
You ready no, you're not ready for this.
(crowd applauds)
You are not ready for this
I've got this, well look out Merrill.
Okay, you did the drop down.
I'm gonna do that too.
- Yeah.
- Do I look?
And then I'm gonna go.
(laughs)
- Now you're tiny and
weak and I'm the opposite.
So the objective of this
exercise is to get past me.
Now, a good idea might
be to cause a distraction
because otherwise there'd
be zero chance of you--
(gasps)
Blueberry!
- That's some cold blooded (bleep).
(applause)
- That was Dave Bautista
and Chloe Coleman in
their new movie, "My Spy".
So Chloe, someone told me that
Dave got a little too intense
on set that, you know, there
might've been a swear jar.
- Oh, you know, actually
he was swearing earlier
backstage, and I have--
- I had to give her 20 bucks backstage.
- Yeah I have 20 bucks,
(laughter)
right here.
He gave me 20 bucks
because of his swearing.
- Oh my gosh.
How much, Dave, do you
think that you contributed
to that jar?
- It got to the point
where I was just like,
I was paying her so much.
- Before you open your mouth
- That I needed credit cause I knew,
I don't know, maybe half of it,
maybe half of it, maybe
nothing, 100 bucks or so.
- Yeah.
- A 100 bucks?
You get it, girl.
- It was like $2 a curse word then,
now its like five bucks.
- Yeah, five bucks a curse word.
- See I tell my kids
you can curse like mommy
when you pay your bills like mommy.
You can say whatever you'd like
as soon as you start paying.
- We were all, I mean we're
okay with it cause we knew,
we were all aware that
there was children on set.
We need to be better about it.
It was just something that once
you're in a rhythm of
speaking a certain way
throughout your life, it's hard
to you know contain control,
but we tried.
- Hard to keep it classy.
(laughs)
- [Chloe] I can understand.
- We made an effort.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- She donated all the money.
- Oh you did?
- Yeah, I donated it to
the Amazon rainforest
because, you know, when it
set on fire it was like--
(audience applauds)
- That's amazing.
- Thank you.
We raised $256,
that's how many people
were swearing onset.
I was just, I was like,
are they really gonna
be this bad about it?
Like how hard is it?
- It is so hard.
Got four children and it's hard,
but I did hear that you
want to be an animator
and you spoke about that a bit already.
But that's really cool.
What a cool--
- Thank you.
- Gift and job and is
that something you really
want to pursue when you're older?
- Yeah, for sure.
I love art, like you know,
when it comes to all of that,
also animating, just creating
a story, but, you know,
not having to make it with real people,
but like when you have an idea
of what you want somebody to look like,
you can bring it to life in animation
and that's what I like about it.
- That's an amazing dream, animation.
- [Chloe] Thank you
- Very cool.
- Thank you.
- So, what did you want to be
when you were a little kid?
- (laughs) I wanted to be alive
and not in jail.
I grew up, you know, not
under great circumstances.
I grew up, I grew up in the hood.
I was surrounded by, you know,
a lot of violence, lot of crime.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was definitely a
product of my environment.
- Yeah.
- I kind of snapped out
of it when I was older
and when I realized it was
just kind of a dead road.
My mom helped me, you know,
she sent me to live with my dad
when I was, I think about 12,
13, when I was bigger than her
and getting in tons of trouble.
So I really didn't, I didn't honestly know
what I wanted to do with my life,
like for the rest of my life
til I was about 30 years old
and that's when I knew
that I wanted to be,
I wanted to entertain people.
- That's so cool, and
so cool to say and own
because a lot of people
give up on their dreams
because they think they've aged out of
whatever bracket society tells
you you're supposed to be in
and that's cool.
Like at 30 you were like,
I wanna do this, yeah.
- My life started at 30, yeah.
I wasted my twenties.
I bounced in nightclubs
from the time I was 17
until I was 30.
- Wow
- Yeah,
that's what I did.
- Right on and you're all gushy
like wishy little teddy bear.
- I'm pretty gushy.
- That's so great.
Your mom is probably like,
wait, what from like your childhood.
- Well even when I went
into professional wrestling
because I was such an introverted kid,
she just like, that's you?
Speaking in front of thousands of people?
I just can't believe it,
but my mom is actually
my biggest fan by far.
- That's so cool, but
let's talk about "My Spy"
because, tell everybody,
if they don't know
what the movie's about,
what it's about.
You want to tell them?
- "My Spy" is kind of about,
you know, this girl Sophie
well, it's about CIA agent.
- Not very good CIA agent.
- And you know, how he
comes across this family.
- He's investigating them.
- [Kelly] He is investigating your family?
- He's not a very good CIA agent
so he's sent out to watch this family.
They're actually looking for the families
a relative of the families
and they think they may catch up with him.
And because he's not
a very good CIA agent,
he's discovered.
- [Kelly] A child catches you.
- And she black mails him. (laughs)
- I love your character.
- [Chloe] Thank you.
- That's amazing
- She's an interesting character.
Like some of the things
she would pull off, like, I don't know.
I wouldn't say in real
life she's, you know,
she's got the nerve to mess
with a guy like this big.
- Yeah.
All you gotta do is push
over his fish, apparently.
- But it's really about people
being misplaced and you know,
kind of learning from each other
and like, she helps me with
things that I need help with
and I help her with things
that she needs help with
and we create a bond and we grow.
- I love these kinds of
movies cause it's so cute,
The connection, you end
up laughing and crying.
- It's a feel good movie
- Yeah, I love that.
Who would be a better spy in real life?
Who's the better liar?
- I say he's a better liar.
- I don't think she can lie.
I don't think she's capable.
I can, I told a few lies in my life.
- Just a few, oh gosh I am
definitely not going to heaven.
- I think she would be the
better spy because she's smarter.
I think she's more clever
and she can also blend in a lot better.
- [Kelly] You think you stand out a bit?
- A little bit, I'm not very discreet.
- Yeah.
I mean like, you know, they have
that cute lie detector
sequence in the movie
and you know, I'm just
saying like the trailer
is just the surface of the entire movie.
Like there's so much more to the film.
- Yeah 'cause they just squeeze them
in those like two minute little--
- The trailer's literally
just the surface of the film.
There's so much more.
- I can't wait, my kids,
we're gonna love watching it.
So thank you so much guys.
(applause)
- Thank you.